we've got the cookies that was way hi
everybody i'm devon abanks the super
proud owner of butter bakery in pasadena
california we've been around for a
little over three years and we made
baked goods and desserts just like
grandma used to make always homemade
from scratch
so today I'm going to teach you how to
make my heath bar cookies heat bars our
milk chocolate covered English toffee I
love English toffee and butter toffee
and all those types of candies so I
figured why not marry the two things
my favorite candy and cookies so to get
started I'm adding white sugar and light
brown sugar the white sugar allows the
cookies to spread where the brown sugar
gives it more of a molasses flavor
the next ingredient that we add is my
most favorite melted butter oh yeah
the next ingredient will just be a
little bit of salt to keep it from being
so overtly sleep so we'll stir the
butter and sugar together until the
sugar is completely dissolved now I'm
going to add two eggs sometimes I'm
pretty good at talking the egg and
opening it with one hand today though
tada
stir the eggs completely until there's
no more yellow once they're fully
incorporated it should look language
carnal so while this is in this state
you can add mix all that in and don't be
afraid of how loose the batter looks
right now our and it's really important
to you when you add flour not to like
pack it in because you don't want to
pack it too deep or too heavy because
it'll change the texture of your cookies
at the end
we're adding the baking soda and you
have to mix the flour and baking soda
until you see no more white keep going
until you see no more flour and no lumps
nothing
so the dole is gonna be very soft still
at this point but don't worry about it
keep going so this is the fun part you
take the heat bars fresh from the
freezer and you slam them on the counter
to break them into pieces and once
they're broken you can just pour them
directly into the batter you want there
to be various sizes of chocolate and
toffee this is what will add a lot of
good texture to your cookie just loosely
mix the candy into the cookie dough you
can chill the dough for about an hour in
the refrigerator so as you can see the
cookie dough is different now it's a
little more solidified so I usually use
ice cream scoop because it makes the
cookies consistent in their size and
what-have-you and if you don't have a
ice cream scoop don't worry about it you
can always just use a regular tablespoon
[Music]
so I'm gonna pop these in the oven and
then I'll check back with you guys when
they're done the cookies are out and
they've been cooling for about 20 10
minutes so now the best part it's time
to try this is my son Jacobi he's here
to eat some cookies you ready to drive
yes I am okay let's try
these are fired especially with the
crunch around the room definitely
crunchy definitely soft in the middle
there's chocolate hints there's toffee I
love the fact that they're sweet and
then a hint of salt the best thing about
this cookie though is the butter it's my
favorite part
know him because he does not everybody
so that guys is my t-bar cookie recipe
let us know what you guys think in the
comments below
yeah do what he said oh and don't forget
to follow us on instagram @ underscore
butter bakery and tick tock and
underscore butter Baker yeah bye guys Oh
[Music]
you